à vous entendre madame tout va bien
alors que les Français le constatent
chaque jour la France devient le pays de
la pénurie pénurie de médicaments
pénurie de carburant pénurie des
transports confrontés à la grève pénurie
d'électricité annoncée pour cet hiver et
face à ces pénuries on fait le terrible
constat que le gouvernement n'a rien
anticipé
il aura fallu plusieurs semaines avant
de réquisitionner une partie du
personnel de quelques raffineries
résultat les Français font la queue
pendant des heures devant les rares
stations services ouvertes la grève
s'étend au centrales nucléaires on
central sur 18 était touchées hier cette
grève si elle se poursuit pourrait
provoquer une terrible pénurie
d'électricité
prévoit d'ailleurs je cite des
conséquences lourdes cet hiver si la
grève se poursuit
qu'attendez-vous pour protéger les
Français des pénuries dans ces secteurs
stratégiques vous faudra-t-il comme pour
les raffineries attendre plusieurs
semaines pour agir allez-vous enfin
réquisitionner toutes les raffineries
allez vous réquisitionner le personnel
des centrales nucléaires allez-vous
mettre en place un service minimum dans
les transports comme le prévoit la
proposition de loi de Bruno retaillod
votez au Sénat la situation exige du
courage et des mesures fortes mais en
avez-vous